[Music]
in not worth it news submitted by JK
over everything hmm
thank you a theme park mascot died after
dancing for only 20 minutes in costume
during a heatwave I used to be a mascot
okay I feel free how does a panther so
you don't think this is funny then you
don't think you were answer I was a
panther you know I understand that your
ass cuts they have a lot of power I
thought you had powers girls like are
you talking about little kids no what's
the draw they think you're cute maybe
one do you like the [ __ ] while you
wear this so you were a panther in high
school how does a panther house mask in
high school yeah the Panther Matt's gone
and therefore you're [ __ ] them yes
because they respect every job in Japan
no matter what you do
listen I would get into fights like
here's the thing in the outfit no no not
an outfit like when you have the outfit
on you get certain privileges that's a
little bit you know what oh yeah I could
they just think you're funny like
there's more eyeballs on what you're
doing
I don't think you'd do that now to 2019
you're gonna be touched in buses in high
school like in high school I gonna flirt
with the girls but like outfit on versus
outfit off there's a big difference
talking about Japan right I'm talking
about a high school you're fair when I
was in high school yes so what I'm just
saying the mascots hasn't that all so
weird like it's pretty known that if
you're on a train in your chick like you
better be careful in chess no he's not
his classmates weren't Japanese people
if he lived on the base so it's American
base American high school but I'm just
saying like you get flirtatious powers
you get you know like there's they don't
even know what's underneath nothing so
then they liked you
because when I had the mascot listen if
I had the mask on this is fine if I have
it off what are you doing oh yeah got a
cute doll love's and ship you were a
panther house Panther you're a black
panther lockouts hey back then it was
only like Jungle Book had black panther
and that was legs right now Black
Panthers like the dopest I was like
that's kind of trend-setting then the
jeffer uh feel like you're gonna get
close to dying and outfit there's high
[ __ ] now some some outfits they have
like little fans in them Wow yeah
they're not disguise let's read about
this but I'm like what a little [ __ ]
it's only 20 minutes I mean I it gets
visit bet okay but do you do this for 20
minutes have you ever tried to be in a
car with the windows closed oh you do
that for 20 minutes and you'll be like
kill me I'd rather die damn it's [ __ ]
hot if you've seen those people grow
because they leave their kids in there
yeah and so adults would be like let's
see what happens after basically five
minutes and it's bad when I worked at
Disney like you see people like take off
your mask back station they'd be
drenched in sweat so like that's why
they only have them come out like oh you
got to show those costumes nasty so this
guy there's a heat wave in Japan this
guy was wearing
unfortunately he was wearing a 35-pound
fairy costume fairy costume dude it's
pretty cute though he didn't use magic
it's a little bit cute I will say so
here's this is the theme park here
that's fine Takashi land oh you must be
a really small guy I feel so bad for
laughing but the I need an outfit like
that yeah that's not the part you died
in the part there's one of those things
that doesn't even seem real I'm lives
matter there you go
they did you I just pictured a sweet old
ass dude that's in there like a little
as old guy he was 28 years old oh
nevermind that's even funnier well I was
gonna say was the overweight did he have
previous health issues high blood
pressure
who knows seems to be perfectly healthy
man ah I mean he probably yeah it his
whole life animal that's what it says
right here
how does hold life ahead of him yeah so
he was it during the full dress
rehearsal they were dancing outside for
20 minutes it wasn't even during the
show it was a rehearsal yeah and then he
collapsed and sucked you didn't even
make it to the show dude he didn't debut
he [ __ ] died during practice so here
it caught apart did I nail that he's
honorable hiragana Park has cancelled
all mascot events in the wake of this
tragedy Dan hey Wes I think you're more
Japanese than I am you lived on Japanese
soil for how long I think 10 years
that's the true Japanese man right here
what was your favorite thing about your
pen ah the culture martial arts not
really the food I don't really like the
food too much yeah I definitely can't do
Korean barbecue you know I like weird
Korean barbecue but that's cooked
yeah that's grilled meat my stomach
you're not in the first time we took him
to Korean barbecue when we first moved
out to LA I'm like yeah you know JJ on
our friend he's Korean and he who is
introducing us all to cream Bob because
I never really did Korean barbecue
either until I moved out here
me too and Wes like within five minutes
of the meat being cooked Westers
disappeared for a good half hour what is
it the grease you can't handle too much
grease listen bro like it I destroyed
that bathroom because like I usually I
never sit on toilets
I just don't so I had to hover oh so
like the arm strength of you know like
[ __ ] you're like an Olympian he's
like doing real and like when I look at
the destruction if you hit the toilet
but it was like I promised like well I
would have never done that by guy I
it needed like an atomic bomb dude you
went over the city you're gonna never
understand though with these things like
when I walk up to a urinal why is there
a puddle of liquid underneath the urinal
I was in do all your nose leak or is
just through a dumpy my seat on it yeah
cuz you don't wanna get splash back
right you splash it on the backrest of
the toilet I'm like how do you miss like
that do you [ __ ] from the back of your
neck or one of those like those slippery
signs in front doors you stand squat on
the ring of the toilet no it's more like
it's more like a yeah but how long you
do this for I can do this for like
thirty seconds you're like doing like a
dip like you're just holding on to the
[ __ ] handicap arm [ __ ] and then the
other thing no wonder comes out like
that the [ __ ] you're all your muscles
are scared those paper ring things
listen wait I will tell you this I think
I did have down everybody I can't I
can't [ __ ] a public bathroom yeah I used
to in high school I lost my school with
a pepper no mergency I would walk I
would leave the school I'd call my mom
okay I called him up I would even tell
the school I was leaving I call my mom
be like mom I'm coming home at the
school cause I ain't take [ __ ] I Drive
home or walk home grab clothes I just
leave and then come back what about now
Oh only time that I really like [ __ ] I
gotta use the bathroom is if I'm flying
internationally because I have no hope
and I'd rather be in the airport then
can I give you a hot tip Nordstrom's
[Laughter]
really oh don't regular Nordstrom
Nordstrom Rack
no they don't want to go with the rack
but Nordstrom's regular Nordstrom's
that's a bathroom experience I should
all over the place but I never bought a
thing I can't do it if I gotta go I
gotta go man I'd rather not deal with
the pain I put down the ring
I'm gonna do I mean if I do but I'll
avoid it like if I know I'll be home in
an hour I'll hold it like if I'm like oh
[ __ ] I got [ __ ] right now I'll be like
oh sweet Lu you wouldn't use our
bathroom though wow it's true cars you
know when you not you can't [ __ ] your
heart out like it's not the same you
don't have the same leg squat e potty
might make a like prairie dogs you know
NS flashback is the worst something in
your body's telling you it's not safe I
think it's primal like it's not it's not
your [ __ ] kitty litter area you know
you're like I don't know where this area
some of my pop out if I can pull a gun
on me or you know like that's why a few
dogs when they [ __ ] they look at their
owners because they're vulnerable so
there look it's the unwritten like
contractor but you got my back you got
my back Bob taking a dump I'm taking a
[ __ ] and if [ __ ] goes down if a wild
animal comes until help me you'll
protect me yeah you got my back yeah
yeah I could [ __ ] anywhere I mean some
places aren't that nice so I would I
would get like a paper towel wet the
toilet seat and put the seat cover on
I got a disinfect it but you guys sit
you guys even with the paper you still
sit on it yeah yeah I'll wipe it down
sometimes and I'll sit on it but then I
could [ __ ] my heart out anywhere boom
yeah usually Eastern coilette are the
ones on the floor and squat those ones
are soft see like for me I would rather
do that yeah Oh cuz I don't you don't
touch anything
well you never sit on the shoes before
that's how I do porta-potties stand over
taking a [ __ ] in there now be my worst
night ever you hover in a four to five
yeah who's puts her ass to the scene a
porta potty I do your part if I need
like I'd rather [ __ ] in a field than
[ __ ] in a port-a-potty
when you're at the beach and you're like
all [ __ ] you use the port I just didn't
[ __ ] no [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
ocean I don't care
you do it are you gonna [ __ ] everyone a
great evolving just when I was a kid I
eat in the ocean just do my swimsuit and
then I could smell the urine from my
crotch oh I know this I know it's a big
[ __ ] way of thinking man how much you
need to drink more water
you smell that when it was dry oh it's
like ten times what that's when you put
a towel around it all day the rest of
the day I was like [ __ ] eight years
old laughs in Myrtle Beach
no one's gonna go to member yeah do the
place work if you were never gonna [ __ ]
in the ocean Myrtle Beach is pretty good
oh yeah [ __ ] baby cheese here that you
can [ __ ] in know they're all murky
they're all like darkened like what do
you want to never get in the Venice
buttes you want to [ __ ] in crystal blue
waters no no you don't had she'd go into
like a white sandy beach and you're just
squatting and you're like what are you
doing nothing and they're just we're
like we can see the [ __ ] if it's crystal
clear you just gotta take a breath and
go to the bottom that [ __ ] what directly
onto the floor and [ __ ] particles go
right in your cover understand and then
push it underwater action happens get
that [ __ ] in the ocean before
what my dog has [ __ ] at the dog beach
and the [ __ ] wave comes and you just
see this [ __ ] rolling back and
forth well you have you seen that like
video I'm sure you can do with like blue
whale I mean yeah the whale sperm what
yeah when they it's a gallons of sperm
why you know but apparently they're like
I don't know it's like gallons yeah it's
like that Islands and gallons of gas
makes heads are so huge like a fat chick
scuba divers ran through it she would
give birth to whales
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you